...
>> SPEAKER: Hello.
I don't know if can you hear me.
Hello?
...:  [PLEASE STAND BY]
[PLEASE STAND BY]
...
>> SPEAKER: Test.
Test.
[PLEASE STAND BY]
...
¶
[Music]
¶ ¶
...
¶
[Applause]
.
Ladies and gentlemen, please
welcome the deputy librarian of
Congress.
[Applause]
.
>> Good evening, everyone, and
thank you for the applause.
It's very nice to have at the
end of the day.
[Laughter]
Welcome to the Library of
Congress.
We're so glad you're here and
the first thing I think we
should do is thank the Fresno
state chamber singers.
They were terrific.
[Applause]
.
They gave a terrific concert
with our post Laureate this
afternoon and what a wonderful
start to our even.
As I speak, we are being live
streamed to Fresno state.
So Fresno state, hello!
How are you?
[Applause]
.
I love Fresno, and I wish I was
there.
Each year, we close the library
library's literary season with
an event honoring our post
Laureate consultant and poetry.
Tonight, we celebrate our
amazing post Laureate, as he con
conchutes his second and final
term.
Juan Felipe Herrera has been one
successful post Laureates ever.
[Applause]
.
From the moment he was appointed
appointed, he has tirelessly
championed the power of poetry
to connect us and empower
audiences across the country by
telling everyone you have a
beautiful voice.
He has put his own beautiful
voice to work for all of us as
well.
As Laureate, he has written poem
issues, and poems that capture
He wrote an inspiring poem, "
"each book is a story" for his
first meeting with Carla Hayden,
our 14th librarian of Congress.
Felipe has been one of the most
active post Laureates ever.
In his first term, he launched
the on online initiative, LA CAS
A D
DE COLORES that includes LAS AMI
AMIA.
He also produced the video
series "El JARDIN" the garden,
in which he walked viewers
through some of the library's
surprising treasures.
For his second term, Juan Filipe
launched the tech color advent
ours of with an collaboration
with JUANA me dean A that swept
second and third graders into
the wonders of the creative
process.
He launched word street
champions and brave builders of
the dream air, year-long project
for Chicago public libraries,
and the poetry foundation, which
schools, Chicago public
libraries, and the poetry
foundation, which gave educators
new strategies for teaching
poetry
his final project, he
created the Laureate lab.
Visual work at the studio.
And innovative space in the
library of California State
University in Fresno, its home
town.
Here, Juan Felipe Herrera mixed
poetry, song and art in
wonderful programs for his local
Juan Felipe Herrera dreamed up
today's celebration, which he
has named Speak the People, the
spark, El Poema.
We begin this even with the
discussion of Latino culture and
national heritage.
Joining on stage will be MARTA
Gonzalez, a CHICANA musician and
assistant professor of Chicano/
Chicano/Latino studies at scrips
singer, song writer and
percussionist for the
award-winning band, QUETZAL.
The leading public radio network
network.
And content producer for the
nation's broadcasting system and
a
Mcactorer genius fell O. Ann
Luis P -- excuse me.
Luis HEREZ, the song writer and
percussionist and guitarist for
the multi Grammy award-winning
band, Los LOBOS, which he
founded in 1973.
The discussion entitleed "Let us
will be moderated by Rafael
Perez Torres, who is a
distinguished author, literary
critic and distinguished
professor at UCLA.
Following the discussion and
after a short break, we are
delighted to welcome MARTA and Q
QUETZAL for one much their very
famous perforrmances.
Dia lot of practice of the
special names.
[Laughter]
I was a French major in college.
So when I got to EL JARDIN, I
wanted to say El
Jedin.
I got through this because of
the wonderful Maria RANA, who is
here with the Library of
Congress.
Marie, thank you for getting me
through, for coaching me.
I'm going to need a lot more in
the future.
In my last two minutes, I'm
going to go off
script just a
moment.
Several weeks ago, the library
received an archive of a
wonderful photo journalist,
Bob Edelman.
Bob side Saddamly died over a
year ago and his archives have
come here.
He was an extremely
interesting photo journalist,
and a confidant of Martinez,
and Andy warhol.
How's that for a range.
But he took wonderful photos
and my dream is one day, we'll
have an exhibit of his work
here.
When we received the gift, we
had a celebration of above
flight and Juan Felipe Herrera
composed a poem in his honor
and it was so moving, and so
inspiring
and captureed Bob so
beautifully.
So I became really, I guess,
inspired
by Juan Felipe's
ability to write this
wonderful poem and I decided I
would write a poem in his
honor.
Now, I know that takes a lot
of Huspa.
I'VE NEVER WRITTEN A POEM IN
MY LIFE.
BUT WHAT CAN I SAY, JUAN
FELIPE HERRERA INSPIRED ME SO
MY POEM CONSISTS OF 50 STANZAS
STANZAS.
NO.
[LAUGHTER]
I PROMISE, I CAN READ IT TO
YOU IN UNDER A MINUTE.
BUT I HAVE TO SAY, I AM I I HAVE
REALLY ENJOYED WRITING IT.
JUAN FELIPE HERRERA'S TENURE
HERES
HERES HAS JUST BEEN SO JOYFUL,
AND HAS ENRICHED ME SO MUCH,
AND JUST OPENED ME UP TO THE
WHOLE POTENTIAL OF POETRY.
BUT I WANTED TO DO SOMETHING
TO THANK HIM AND REALLY HONOR
HIM.
SO HERE IT GOES.
MY POEM ISITY TOLD J.F.H.
J. JUAN A JOURNEY FULL OF BOND
BONDER AND SURPRISE REVEALED
AS POST, PERFORMER, WRITER,
CARTOONIST, ANTHROPOLOGIST,
TEACHER, ACTIVIST, POST
LAUREATE, YET A SON SON OF
MIGRANT
MIGRANTS WHO NEVER FORGET.
F. FELIPE.
ALAN BEGINSBERG REVEALED FROM
TIME TO TIME THROUGH LANDSCAPE
AND -- ALAN GINSBERG, REVEALED
FROM TIME TO TIME, ALWAYS
REMINDED
REMIND US OF RISK, OF SUFFER
SUFFERING, FAMILY, ANGUISH AND
TIME.
H. HERERRA.
HUMBLE, YET FULL OF THE DEVIL.
AND FULL OF BOB DYLAN AND
WOODY GUTHREY AND FREEDA
CALLOW AND CAT STEVENS AND
ROSA PARKS AND FARMERS AND
SORROW AND LOSS.
J.F.H. POST LAUREATE, POST FOR
LIFE.
THE END.
[APPLAUSE].
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
.
L THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
FLATTERING ME
WITH THAT APPLAUSE.
I FEEL BETTER AND NO ONE THREW
ANYTHING AT ME.
SO WITHOUT FURTHER ADO, MAY I
PRESENT OUR POST LAUREATE,
JUAN FELIPE HERRERA AND OUR
DISTINGUISHED GUESTS.
THANK YOU MUCH.
[APPLAUSE]
.
>> L THANK YOU ALL FOR COMING
OUT TONIGHT.
WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE IT,
AND I THINK WE'RE IN FOR A
VERY SPECIAL EVEN OF STORIES
AND MUSIC, AND I'D JUST LIKE
TO SAY, IT'S MY GREAT HONOR TO
BE HERE AND IT'S MY GREAT
PRIVILEGE TO BE HERE, AND TO
WELCOME YOU ALL THIS EVEN.
AT THE CLOSING CEREMONY,
RECOGNIZING AND CELEBRATING
JUAN FELIPE HERRERA AS OUR
POST LAUREATE OF THE UNITED
STATES.
[APPLAUSE]
.
I THINK HIS POETRY IS
SIGNIFICANT TO US, BECAUSE IT
SINGS TO OUR HEARTS.
IT TOUCHES EACH ONE OF US, BUT
IT ALSO SPEAKS OF THE EARTH.
IT SPEAKS OF HISTORY.
IT SPEAKS OF TIME.
IT CONNECTS US PROFOUNDLY, TO
A FELT SENSE OF PLACE BOTH IN
TERMS OF BEING IN A SPECIFIC
GEOGRAPHY AND LIVING HISTORY,
AND BEING CONNECTED TO ANNEX
TENSEIVE HISTORY.
HE MAKES US FEEL LOCATED IN A
CONTINUUM OF BELONGING,
WHETHER IT BE OUR ROOTS AS
AMERICANS INDIGENOUS TO THIS
CONTINENT OR BE IT AS A RESULT
OF OUR ANCESTORS OR US,
INDIVIDUALLY, FLYING OR
WALKING OR SWIMMING HOWEVER WE
GOT TO THE UNITED STATES, TO
BECOME A PART OF THIS UNION.
AND THIS UNION
THAT JUAN
FELIPE HERRERA REPRESENTS WE
ARE HERE TO RECOGNIZE JUAN
FILIPE'S VOICE, ARIZONA IT HAS
CONTRIBUTED TO OUR BELONG TO
THE WORD.
OUR SENSE OF CONNECTION TO
EACH OTHER, AND OUR SENSE OF
RECOGNITION TO OURSELVES,
THROUGH HIS POETRY.
SO I'D LIKE TO INVITE JUAN
FELIPE HERRERA TO READ A POEM,
LET US COME TOGETHER IN IN IN IN
A
FLAREISHING WAY, WHICH OUR EVEN
IS DEDICATED TO, AND THEN TO
TALK MAYBE FOR A FEW MINUTES
ABOUT HIS SPECIESES WITH THE F
FLORICANTOMOVEMENT IN THE 19
1970'S.
THE CHICANO POETRY MOVEMENT
THAT BROUGHT ART AND SOCIAL
ACTIVISM TOGETHER, AND BROUGHT
THEM TOGETHER IN A COLLECTIVE,
DEDICATED TO TRANSFORMING THE
WORLD IN WHICH THEY LIVE, AND
THE WORLD IN WHICH THEY
THOUGHT WE WOULD BE LIVE BEING
IN.
SO JUAN FELIPE HERRERA.
I INVITE YOU TO SHARE YOUR
WORDS  WITH US.
IF YOU WOULD READ THE POEM FOR
US.
>> YES, THIS IS 1971 AND I
WAS WALKING DOWN CAMPBELL HALL
HALL, AT UCLA AND OUT OF
NOWHERE, THE PHRASE "LET US
GATHER
IN FLOURISHING WAYS"
SPOKE TO ME AND I REALLY NEED
PHRASE.
THAT'S SOMETHING I WANT TO
WRITE ABOUT.
LET US GATHER IN A FLOURISHING
WAY, LOOSE GRAINS
LET US
GATHER.
GIVING BIRTH, GIVING NEW
BEGINNINGS.
DULCES, FRESCOS, VERDES.
TURQUOISE STRONG.
LET US GATHER IN A FLOURISHING
WAY.
IN LA LUZ, IN THE LIGHT, IN
THE CARNE, IN THE FLESH.
FIELDS OF BLOSSOM, JUNTOS.
LOS BRAZOS, TOGETHER IN PEACE
W RAIN AND LAMANANA.
TEMPRANA, EARLY, DAY BREAK ON
OUR FOREHEAD.
CALOR, HEAVEN OF HEAT AND
WISDOM TO MEET US ALWAYS IN
THE GARDEN OF OUR STRUGGLE
ENJOY.
LET US OFFER OUR HEARTS
TO
GREET OUR RISING FREEDOM.
WOVEN BRAZOS, BRANCHES, PIEDRA
PIEDRAS, STONES, CACTI, NOPALE
NOPALES.
AVOCADOS, RIPE, MARIPOSA,
BEAUTER FLY CLEAR OCEANS  AND
CLEAR SEAS OF OUR FAITH TO
BREATHE.
ALL OF US, EL CAMINO, ON THE
ROAD, ON THIS ROAD.
BLISSING TO GIVE,
TO GROW.
THE CREATE CITY IN LAS MANOS,
NUESTRO AMOR.
[APPLAUSE]
.
>> CAN YOU TELL US A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THAT PERIOD AND
PERIOD THAT CAME JUST AFTER
.
>> JUAN: IT'S KIND OF UN
UNDESCRIBABLE.
YOU PUT, LET'S SEE, YOU PUT FR
FRIJOLES, AFFIRMATIVE
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION
BERETS, LEAVING HOME.
FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER.
FIRST TIME, FIRST GENERATION.
GO TO THAT PLACE CALLED I
DON'T KNOW.
UCLA IS A NEW TIME, A NEW EPIC
EPIC.
A NEW WORLD.
THAT DAY CAME WHEN THE BIG
ENVELOPE FROM UCLA CAME.  AND
ELOISA, WHO I MET IN 1962 WHEN
WE WERE BOTH IN MIDDLE SCHOOL.
WHO BECAME ONE OF ONE OF A
PIONEERING
CHICANO POST.
WHO STARTED CRACKING THE
ANTHROPOLOGY BOOKS
HE SAYS,
TODAY, I'M A CHICANO.
I SAID WHAT WERE YOU YESTERDAY
YESTERDAY?
[LAUGHTER]
SO IT WAS LIKE THAT
PLAYING IN
THE LAST OF THE COUGH EF
HOUSES WE WOULD GO THERE,
LUISA AND I, AND WE'D JUMP IN,
AND WE'D PLAY CON NGAS AND I'D
GET UP WITH HARMONICA.
WHILE THERE WAS A DIGUITAR
THAT SANG BLUES.
HOT CIDER WITH SIN
MONEY STICK
STICKS  IN IT
AND PEOPLE WERE
SINGING, A PIRATE, A POST, YOU
KNOW, SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
AND YOU PUT ALL THAT STUFF
TOGETHER, AND YOU PUT THE
EXPLOSION OF THE UNION MOVE
MOVEMENT AND THE PILGRIMAGES,
LA VIRGIN DE GUADELUPE.
AND YOU PUT TREKS  TO MEXICO.
TRICKS TO CUBA AND TRICKS BACK
AND LIVING ON RICE
WATER.
AND IT IS VERY EXCITED ABOUT
THE FACT THAT WE ACTUALLY, HAD
A VOICE, AND WE TOOK ONE OF
THE TASKS AND SOON, WE STARTED
WORK.
COLLECTIVE
, IN SAN FRANCISCO,
AND THE WOMEN BEGAN TO GATHER
IN COTTAGES, AND THEY WENT TO
COTTAGES AS A COLLECTIVE, AND
ALL OF A SUDDEN, THEY WERE
LIKE, LIVING IN THEIR OWN
WORLD, AND THE WOMAN WORLD AND
ASSERTING THE WORLD ON THEIR
OWN TERMS
SO ALL THAT IS
TAKING PLACE WHILE THIS IS
BEGINNING TO COOK, AND WE'RE
EXCITED BECAUSE ALL OF A S IT
REALLY WASN'T ABOUT RIDING.
OR BEING A POST.
IT WAS ABOUT STANDING UP.
AND SPEAKING.
FOR OUR COMMUNITIES, AND TO
OPEN UP AND BREAK OPEN THOSE
VAULTS THAT HAD OUR STORIES,
OUR WORK, OUR SYMBOLS AND
SIGNS, AND THE MANY WAYS OF
OUR PEOPLE, AND WE WANTED TO
BREAK OPEN THOSE VOLTS, AND
STEP IN TO SEE THEM AND WORDS
AND FORMS, AND SONGS  AND
MUSIC WERE A PART OF THAT
EFFORT AND PROJECT, AND I'M SO
HAPPY THAT WE'RE HERE TODAY.
ECHOING THESE THINGS, ACTUALLY
ACTUALLY, RECREATING AND
STARTING A GREAT PANEL TODAY
IN EVERYONE THAT'S HERE.
>> AND THE IDEA OF VOICE, AND
SHARING VOICE K COLLECTING
VOICE SYSTEM ONE OF THE THINGS
WE WANT TO TALK ABOUT TODAY AS
A PANEL, IN ORDER TO GET TO
HERRERA HAS LEFT US, AS POST
LAUREATE, BUT HOW HE IS
WORKING AS A LATINO LITERARY
CULTURAL TRADITION THAT,
BRINGS MANY OF US TOGETHER AND
CARRIES WITH IT, CERTAIN
VALUES THAT HAVE TRANSFORMED
THE NATIONAL CULTURE AND HAVE
PRODUCTIVELY CONTRIBUTED TO
THE NATIONAL CULTURE.
SO I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE THE
REST OF THE PANEL TO YOU AND
I'D LIKE EACH OF THEM IN TURN,
TO MAYBE TALK A LITTLE BIT HOW
THEY CAME TO THE IDEA, THE
REALIZATION, HAVING A VOICE,
WANTING  TO SHARE A VOICE, AND
WANTING TO SHARE THEIR VOICE
WITH OTHERS TO FORM NEW
COLLECTIVES AND TO BOTH THINK
IN TERMS OF THE SOCIAL WORLD
THAT THEY INHERITED, THAT WE
HAVE INHERITED, AND THAT WE EN
ENVISION TRANSFORMING, BUT
ALSO, THE ESTHETIC WORLD, THE
ARTISTIC WORLD, THAT THESE
ARTISTS HAVE WORKED VERY HARD
AS WELL, TO TRANSFORM, AND
TRANSFORM THE MEDIA THAT EACH
OF THESE INDIVIDUALS HAS USED
IN ORDER TO CHALLENGE THE
NATURE OF THAT MEDIA, AS THAT
MEDIA CHALLENGES THE NATURE OF
OUR SOCIAL HEARD, AND SOCIAL
HIERARCHY.
I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE TO YOU,
MARTA GONZALEZ, MY FRIEND, AND
WHICH I CHICANA  A ACTIVISTA, A
MUSICIAN.
FEMINIST MUSIC THEATER, AT
LATINO AND LATINO STUDIES AT
SCRIPS COLLEGE IN CLAREMONT,
CALIFORNIA.
SHE IS A BRILLIANT SCHOLAR, AS
WELL AS A BRILLIANT MUSICIAN
AND SHE HAS RECEIVED FELLOW
SHIPS FROM THE FULL BRIGHT
FOUNDATION, FROM THE FORD
FOUNDATION AND WOODROW WILSON
FELLOWSHIP FOUNDATION, WHICH
IS VERY IMPRESSIVE FOR A YOUNG
SCHOLAR, WHO'S JUST -- I WON'T
SAY STARTING OUT.
SHE'S CONTRIBUTED QUITE A BIT
ALREADY TO OUR FIELD BOTH
MUSICALLY, AND INTELLECTUALLY
AND HER ACADEMIC INTEREST, AND
THIS IS WHAT IS BEAUTIFUL
THROUGH HER CAREER.
INTERTWINED, AND COMBINED AND
ARE COMPLETE COMPLETELY
INSEPARABLE,
AND ORGANIC AND HER ACADEMIC
INTERESTS ARE FUELED BY HER MU
STILLSHIP, FOR THE SINGER SONG
WRITER, FOR THE AWARD-WINNING
BAND QUETZAL, WHO HAVE MADE
CONSIDERABLE IMPACT IN THE LOS
ANGELES MUSIC SCENE, AND THE
MUSIC SCENE IN THE STATES MORE
BROADLY.
SHE AND HER PARTNER HAS BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN CATALYZEING THE
TRANSNATIONAL DIALOGUE BETWEEN
CHICANA AND LATINA COMMUNITIES
COMMUNITIES, AND THE HAROCHO
COMMUNITIES, A FORM OF RHYTHM
AND MUSIC THAT IS TYPICALLY
TRADITIONAL OF THAT REGION OF
MEXICO AND IT'S JUST ANNEX
EXTRAORDINARILY RICH FORM OF
USEIC.
THAT HAS VERY, VERY DEEP ROOTS
N INDIGENOUS SOUNDS AND
AFRICAN SOUNDS.
IN 2014, HER STOMP BOX WHICH
WAS FEATURED EARLY ON THE
STAGE, IT WAS USED AS A
PLATFORM.
>> A BAROS ONE.
>> IT'S A SOUND BOX USE
FORWARD DANCING.
HER TARIMA WAS ACQUIRED BY THE
NATIONAL MUSEUM OF NATIONAL
HISTORY, BECAUSE OF THE
WONDERFUL WORK THAT SHE AND QU
QUETZAL HAVE UNDERTAKEN N
TERMS OF THEIR MUSICIANSHIP
AND WORK FOR THE COMMUNITY.
THEY HAVE JUST RELEASE AID NEW
ALBUM "THE ETERNAL GETDOWN"
BEING PRODUCED BY SMITHSONIAN
LABEL.  AND IT IS MY GREAT
PLEASURE TO BRUCE MORGAN TO
YOU, MARTA GONZALEZ.
>> IT'S A RELOAN OR TO BE UP
HERE WITH THESE ARTISTS, AND
THINKERS AND POST LAUREATES.
IT'S SUCH AN HONOR TO BE HERE,
I WAS ALL TORN UP IN THE
BATHROOM, AND I THOUGHT, WHAT
AM I DOING HERE?
ANY HOW, T.M.I.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT I HAD TO SAY THAT.
I REALLY FEEL SO MUCH
INFLUENCE DIRECTLY, BY ALL OF
THESE MEN UP HERE IN SOME WAY,
SO I'M VERY HAPPY TO BE HERE
AND I'M ALSO PROUD TO BE ONE
OF THE FEW WOMEN UP HERE AS
WELL.
THE ONLY WOMAN UP HERE.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
.
JUST SO YOU KNOW, THERE ARE
MANY OTHERS.
AND THINKING ABOUT VOICE,
THERE ARE TWO THINGS I'D LIKE
TO SAY ABOUT THAT AND ONE OF
THE THINGS IS FIRST OF ALL,
YOU NEED TO SEE AN EXAMPLE.
TO FIND A VOICE FOR ME IS
SEEING SOMEBODY ELSE, EXPRESS.
LIKE THE BEAUTIFUL WORDS THAT
OUR POST LAUREATE SAID AT THIS
TIME IT'D.
YOU PUT A MIRROR TO THE FACE.
AND SHOW YOU HOW BEAUTIFUL
YOUR CULTURE IS AND HOW IT'S
NOT BAD TO MIX ENGLISH AND
SPANISH, AND TO CREATE NEW
LANGUAGE LIKE SPANGLISH AND
SAY IT IN A WAY THAT FULFILLS
WITH YOU PRIDE, WHERE YOU
FLUFF UP
I HAVE AN UNDER
GRADUATE DEGREE I WENT TO UCLA
AND EVEN THOUGH THIS WONDERFUL
MAN GRACED THE HALLWAYS OF
THIS PLACE, UNFORTUNATELY,
THERE ARE ELEMENTS AT UCLA
CHANGE THAT WOULD MUCH.
I IMAGINE, IT WAS EVEN MORE
EXPRESSIVE BACK IN THE DAY.
BUT IN MY TIME, YOU COULD RUN
INTO GREAT SCHOLARS, OF COURSE
COURSE, BUT TO KNOW THAT WELL,
JUAN FILIPE HAS BEEN THERE,
AND TON THAT HE'S AN INFLUENCE
OTHERS TRAJECTORY AND BODY OF
WORK THAT WE HAVE IS EXTREME
EXTREMELY IMPACTFUL.
SO FOR ME, IS TO WITNESS AND
SEE READINGS SUCH AS THESE,
SUCH AS SANDRA CISNEROS,
SHERRY MORAGA, SO MANY POETS
THAT REFLECTED MY EXPERIENCE,
WELL, THE FIRST THING IS AN
EXAMPLE, THE SECOND THING, I
THINK FOR ME HAS BEEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A LIGHT IN
YOUR FACE AND BE ABLE TO SAY
SOMETHING ONCE IN YOUR LIFE.
SOMEONE PUTS THE MIC IN YOUR
FACE, GO AHEAD.
WHAT WERE YOU THINKING?
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO CONTRIBUTE
CONTRIBUTE?
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO SAY?
AT SOME POINT, YOU TAKE IT
SERIOUSLY, AND YOU'RE GIVEN
THE OPPORTUNITY.
AND WOW, NOBODY'S EVER ASKED
ME WHAT I THINK, WHAT I EN
ENVISION FOR THE FUTURE, WHAT
I CAN IMAGINE, WHAT I STAND TO
CREATE.
WHAT I STAND TO CREATE, AND
CONTRIBUTE.
SO FIRST, IT WAS AN EXAMPLE OF
MUJERAS AND OTHER WONDERFUL
POETS.
FOR ME, IT WAS ALSO HAVING THE
OPPORTUNITY, AND I THINK MY
BAND QUETZAL AND WHEN I MET MY
PARTNER, HE SAID, WHY DON'T
YOU WRITE SOMETHING.
WHAT?
TELL ME WHAT TO SING.
I'M NOT GOING TO TELL WHAT YOU
TO SING.
YOU'RE THE SINGER.
I WAS LIKE DANG, SO NEXT THING
YOU KNOW, I HAD TO WRITE.
AND I REALLY STARTED PAYING
ATTENTION TO WORD SMITHING
AND HOW THINGS WERE BEING PUT
TOGETHER AND IT BECAME REALLY
EXCITING.
AND AS AN EXAMPLE, AND THEN
THE OPPORTUNITY.
>> THANK YOU.
[APPLAUSE]
.
>> NEXT, I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE
HUGO MORALE S' , THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL
LATINO
NETWORK.
HE IMMIGRATED TO THE U.S. AT
THE AGE OF 9 WITH HIS FAMILY
TO SONOMA COUNTY.
HE JOINED HIS FATHER, WORKING
IN THE CALIFORNIA FARM FIELDS
AT THE AGE OF 9.
HE ATTENDED PUBLIC SCHOOLS,
AND EVENTUALLY, ATTENDED
HARVARD COLLEGE AND HARVARD
LAW SCHOOL.
EVEN DURING THOSE YEARS, HE
CONTINUED TO WORK IN THE
FIELDS WITH HIS FAMILY.
HE FOUND THE RADIO BILINGUAL
IN FRESNO, CALIFORNIA, IN 1976
1976.
RADIO BILINGUE HAS 12 FULL
POWER FM RADIO STATIONS,
SERVING THE SOUTHWEST MEXICAN
BOARDER AND HAS 16 RADIO
AFFILIATES IN MEXICO.
HE RECEIVED MCCARTHY
FOUNDATION FELLOWSHIP, WHICH
YOU MIGHT KNOW THE AS THE
GENIUS FELLOWSHIP AND
SUBSEQUENTLY, RECEIVED THE CPB
EDWARD MURRAY AWARD AND
CULTURAL AWARD.
HE HAS TWIN BOYS, AGE 8.
THEY MAKE THEIR HOME IN FRENO,
CALIFORNIA, BUT TONIGHT, HE IS
HERE WITH US IN WASHINGTON DD.
C AND IT IS MY GREAT PLEASURE
TO INTRODUCE HUGO MORALES.
[APPLAUSE]
.
>> GRACIAS, RAFAEL.
>> WHAT MAKES ME RAISE MY
VOICE.
I'M AN INDIO FROM AWAY HAWKA
AS CHILDREN, WE ARE NOT
SUPPOSED TO RAISE OUR VOICE.
EVEN IN SCHOOL.
[MICROPHONE FEEDBACK]
>> YOUR MIC IS A LITTLE --
>> THERE WE GO.
>> OKAY.
MUCH BETTER.
[APPLAUSE]
.
SO ANYWAY, I'LL TALK A LITTLE
BIT LATER ABOUT TECHNOLOGY.
SO ANY WAY, SO IT WAS VERY
INTERESTING, BECAUSE LIKE ANY
CHILD, WE HAVE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS, RIGHT?
BUT I COULD NOT ASK THAT AND I
WAS RAISE BY THE A SINGLE MOM,
BECAUSE MY FATHER, RAFAEL WAS
IN THE UNITED STATES
WORKING.
SO WHAT HAPPENED IS, AS A
CHILD, I WAS ACTUALLY VERY
TIMID AND A MAMMA'S BOY.
I WAS ALWAYS WITH MY MOTHER,
AND BEING PROTECTIVE.
BUT THEN MY FATHER, AROUND 19
1967, AND THEN NEXT YEAR, HE
BROUGHT THE WHOLE FAMILY.
THE BROTHER, WE JOINED HIM IN
CALIFORNIA, IN SONOMA COUNTY.
SO IT WAS VERY INTERESTING,
BECAUSE THERE'S WHERE I GOT
INTRODUCED TO MULTI CULTURAL
CULTURALLISM.
I DID PICK PRUNES, AND CROPS.
POOR BLACK KIDS, POOR WHITE
KIDS.
FILIPINOS, SO ALL THIS KIND OF
CAME TOGETHER
.
WE ENLISTED IN ONE LABOR CAMP
AND WE STAYED THERE.  WE WERE
REALLY EXCITED TO SEE LIKE
FELIPE'S FAMILY, TO COME BY.
WE WERE MEETING NEW KIDS IN
THE SUMMERS.
SO ANY WAY, SO IT WAS AROUND,
I THINK WHEN I WAS 12, 13
YEARS OLD, I REALLY REALIZED I
HAD TO SPEAK OUT.
OF COURSE, I WAS BROUGHT HERE
TO THE UNITED STATES
BY THE
AGE OF 12, I DEVELOPED
TUBERCULOSIS.
I WAS IN A SANITARIUM SANITARIUM
FOR A
WHOLE YEAR.
SO WITH NO BATH, NO BATHROOM,
NO RADIO, NO TV, SO THAT WAS
TIME.
I BEGAN TO READ WHAT SOME OF
THE PEOPLE THOUGHT.
ABOUT POOR PEOPLE.
THAT THEY DESERVE TO BE POOR.
THEY DIDN'T TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
OPPORTUNITY.
SO THAT'S WHEN AND OTHER
THINGS, AND HOW THEY THOUGHT
ABOUT US.
THEY WERE DIRTY, UNDESERVING,
ET CETERA.
AND ALSO, WE DESERVED TO BE
POOR BECAUSE WE DIDN'T HAVE
THE INITIATIVE OR THE
MENTALITY.
THAT'S WHAT I DECIDED TO SPEAK
OUT.
-- SO WHAT I DID IS, I CALLED,
I DID A CALL OUT TO THE
COMMUNITY FROM THE RADIO
STATION, TO THE ENTIRE BOSTON
AREA AND THAT'S HOW I I WAS
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE ON THE
RADIO.
SO I GAVE THE VOICE TO THE
PUERTO RICAN COMMUNITY IN
BOSTON.
AND THEN ALSO TO ALL THE
LATINOS.
I ENDED UP [INDISCERNIBLE] THE
SOUND INITIAL OF ALL THINGS
AND THEN I GOT THE IDEA OF OF
ROAD
ALL THE FARMWORKES, WERE
LISTENING
LISTENING IN SO
NOPE -- --
SONOMA, NAPA COUNTY, AND JUAN
FELIPE HERRERA INVITED THE
AUDIENCE FOR THE LONGEST POEM
IN THE WORLD AND HERE THE
OTHER PEOPLE THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD.
[APPLAUSE].
>> AND TO MY LEFT IS LOUIE
PEREZ, AN AMERICAN SONG WRITER
WRITER, A PROSE WRITER, GUITAR
GUITARIST, COMPOSER.
FOR THE MULTI GRAMMY
AWARD-WINNING AND ROCK AND
ROLL ALL OF FAME, NOMINATED
FAN, LOS LOBOS.
[APPLAUSE]
.
LOUIE IS THE GROUP'S PRIMARY
LYRICIST, AND IS A KEEN
OBSERVER OF THE HUMAN
CONDITION, IF YOU KNOW HIS
WORK.
WHICH HAS BEEN SHOW CASE BOD
EVERY LOS LOBOS RECORDING,
BEGINNING WITH "A TIME TO
DANCE" IN 1983 AND UP TO THE
MOST RECENT ALBUM "GATE OF
GOLD" IN 2013.  AND HE COWROTE
SONGS  WITH DAVID HILDAGO.
HE WROTE SONGS AS WELL FOR
TONY KUSHNER'S, ADAPTION OF
THE GOOD PERSON OF SESC SCHWAN.
ESTRANGE LEAN, THE QUEEN OF
MAKE BELIEF, THIS PLAY
PREMIEREED IN LOS ANGELES.
HIS SONGS, AS MANY SONGS, OF
COURSE COVERED BY
EXTRAORDINARY ARTISTS,
INCLUDING WAYLIN JENNINGS,
ROBERT GARCIA.
HIS PROSE HAVE BEEN PUBLISHED
IN MANY PLACES, AND HE HAS
SERVED AS THE DIRECTOR FOR A
NUMBER OF ALBUM PACKAGES, AND
AS ARTISTIC DIRECTOR FOR A
NUMBER OF ALBUMS, INCLUDING
NOMINATED FOR A GRAMMY AWARD
FOR BEST BOX RECORDING PACKAGE
PACKAGE.
AS A VISUAL ARTIST, HE HAS
SHOWN HIS PAINTINGS AND
SCULPTURES IN MANY PROMINENT
GALLERIES AND MUSEUMS ACROSS
THE NATION AND ACROSS LOS
ANGELES.
HE IS CURRENTLY WORKING ON A
CAREER RETROSPECTIVE BOOK OF
HIS LYRICS AND WE'RE WE'RE
GOING TO WORK TOGETHER TO GET
THAT FINISHED AND THIS IS A
BOOK OF LYRICS, WRITING, AND
ARTS THAT WILL BE PUBLISHED
SOON.  AND IT IS MY GREAT
PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE LOUIE
PEREZ.
[APPLAUSE]
.
>> IT'S REALLY GREAT TO BE
HERE.
WE WERE TALKING IN THE GREEN
ROOM WHEN, WE FIRST MET BACK
IN THE EARL 70'S, AT BALBOA
PARK, AT CENTER CULTURAL SAN
DIEGO, WAY BACK WHEN OUR HAIR
WAS ABOUT A FOOT LONGER AND A
LOT DARKER AND IT'S GREAT TO
BE HERE.
THIS CRAZY THING CALLED
ANOTHER STARTED WITH ME A LONG
TIME AGO, WHEN I WAS A KID
GROWING UP IN EAST L.A.
AND ACTUALLY, IT WAS KIND OF
LIKE A PROCESS OF ELIMINATION.
I WAS A TERRIBLE DANCER AND
I
COULDN'T SWIM TO SAVE MY LIFE
AND I WAS EVEN A WORSE
BASEBALL PLAYER SO I BECAME A
MUSICIAN.
AS AN INSPIRATION, I WAS
LISTENING TO MEXICAN MUSE THAT
I CAN MY MOTHER PLAYED AT HOME
HOME.
SHE SANG AT HOME AND INSPIRED
ME IN MANY WAYS.
OF COURSE, I LISTENED TO RADIO
RADIO.
MEXICAN MUSIC WHEN I WAS VERY
LITTLE, AND BY THE TIME I GOT
OLD ENOUGH TO BE ABLE TO REACH
THE KNOB ON THE RADIO, I
DISCOVERED, THAT'S WHEN JIMMY
HENDRIX, JAMES BROWN, AND
EVERYBODY IN BETWEEN CAME INTO
MY LIFE.
MY MOTHER BOUGHT ME A GUITAR
WHEN I WAS 12 YEARS OLD IN
SORT OF HER OWN YOUTH DI
DIVERSION PROGRAM.
I THINK IT WAS TO KEEP ME OFF
THE STREET BECAUSE SHE LOVED
MUSIC, TOO.
SHE ALSO INSPIRED ME BY THE
THINGS THAT SHE DID.
I ALSO GREW UP WITHOUT A
FATHER.
HE DIED WHEN I WAS ABOUT 8
YEARS OLD.
STRONG WOMEN, RIGHT?
[APPLAUSE]
.
SHE TAUGHT ME BY HER EXAMPLE
BY FEEDING HOMELESS PEOPLE ON
MY FRONT PORCH.
ONE DAY WHEN I CAME UP THE
WALK, SHE WAS, THERE WAS A
HOMELESS PERSON DRINKING OUT
OF MY KOOL-AID MUG I HAD SENT
FOR IN THE MAIL.
AND I WAS KIND OF APPALLED BY
THAT AND THEN I REALIZED, MY
MOTHER WAS ACTUALLY TEACHING
ME SOMETHING.
SHE WAS TEACHING ME THAT IN
THIS LIFE, WE REALLY DON'T OWN
ANYTHING AND IF WE DO, WE HAVE
TO SHARE WITH OTHERS.
SO MUSICALLY, YOU KNOW, I
LISTENED TO EVERYTHING I COULD
PH I COULD GET MY HANDS O. LOS
LOBOS FORMED IN 1973, KIDS
GROWING UP IN EAST L.A. AND WE
PUT AWAY ELECTRIC GUITARS,
BECAUSE WE WERE ALL IN ROCK
BANDS AND WE FORMED  IN BAND
TO PLAY TRADITIONAL MEXICAN
MUSIC, WHICH WAS UNHEARD OF AT
THE TIME.
WE WERE TIPPAL EARLY 70'S KIDS
WITH LONG HAIR AND FLANNEL
SHIRTS, PLAYING MEXICAN MUSIC.
SO IT WAS KIND OF UNHEARD OF
AT THE TIME.
BUT
CHICANO MOVIMIENTOAND WE
LENT OUR MUSICAL SERVICES TO
CESAR CHAVEZ AND UNITED
FARMWORKERS, AND JUST ABOUT
ANY CHICANO CAUSE HAPPENING AT
THE MOMENT, WHICH IS MANY.
WE FOUND A REGULAR GIG IN
PLAYING AT ALL THE MECCHAS IN
CALIFORNIA, AT STATE COLLEGES,
AND UNIVERSITY.
I GREW UP IN EAST LOS ANGELES.
IT'S A SPRING OF BEAUTY, PAIN,
SORROW AND JOY.
SO I DRAW FROM THAT FROM ALL
OF MY WORK.
IT'S A BOTTOMLESS AND
BOUNTIFUL AMOUNT OF EXPERIENCE
THAT I CAN DRAW FROM AND I
CAN'T SAY ENOUGH ABOUT WHERE
WE COME FROM.
I'LL NEVER FORGET, AND IT IS
CLOSE TO MY HEART THIS DAY.
[APPLAUSE]
.
I THINK OUR SPEAKERS HAVE EACH
NOTED THE WAY IN WHICH THEIR
CONNECTION TO LOBOS CAL
LOWELL, AND THE
INFLUENCE OF OTHER WHO IS CAME
BEFORE, THE IMPORTANCE OF
PARENTS, ROLE MODELS.
FIGURES, WHO'S MODEL WE CAN
DRAW UPON.
WHO'S IMAGES AND LESSONS WE
COULD DRAW UPON, IN ORDER TO
MOVE THINGS FORWARD AND
EARLIER JUAN FELIPE HERRERA IN
HIS POETRY STATED, THIS
AFTERNOON, IN THE PREVIOUS
EVENT, OUR ANCESTORS GIVE US
THEIR VOICE.
OUR ANCESTORS GIVE US THEIR
VOICE TO SPEAK AGAIN.
THAT'S A BEAUTIFUL SENTIMENT,
AND I THINK THAT ENCAPSULATES
THE SENSE OF TRADITION AND THE
COMMITMENT TO TRADITION THAT
IS A PART OF LATINO CULTURE,
LATINO HERITAGE AND PART OF
WHAT GIVES LATINO COMMUNITIES,
A SENSE OF STRENGTH, AND
PURPOSE.
BUT I'D LIKE TO ASK EACH OF
OUR PANEL MEASURES, WHAT
TRADITION SIGNIFIES WHAT, IT
MEANS TO THEM.
WHAT IS TRADITION AS FAR AS
BEING A WELL SPRING, BUT ALSO
PERHAPS BEING A SOURCE OF
CONCERN.
ARE THERE TRADITIONS THAT ARE
PERHAPS BEST LEFT BEHIND
BEHIND
TRADITION KECKSES  TO THE PAST
AND ALLOWSES  TO MOVE INTO THE
FUTURE
.
VIOLENCE AGAINST WOMEN SHOULD
BE STOPPED.
[APPLAUSE].
ALCOHOLISM, I THINK SHOULD BE
STOPPED.
AMONG MY PEOPLE.
THIS IS TOO MUCH.
TOO MUCH ALCOHOL CONSUMPTION
AND TO ME, IT APPEARS TO BE A
CONSPIRACY, I DON'T KNOW BY
WHOM.
DEFINITELY, CORPORATIONS, TO
KEEP US DRUNK.
AND IT'S JUST SUCH A TERRIBLE
THING TO SEE DRUGS AND
VIOLENCE AMONG OUR NATIVE
PEOPLE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF BRIGHT,
TALENTED FOLKS.
SO I'D LIKE TO SEE THAT GOING.
BUT WHAT I DO WANT TO SAY IS
THIS INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF
POTTERY, FOR EXAMPLE, OR
DANCE
OF THE DIABLOS.
CELEBRATE OUR SPIRIT AS INDIOS
AND SPIRIT IN OUR HEARTS AND
WE DANCED TO THE BEAUTY OF OUR
PEOPLE, AND THE BEAUTY OF OUR
FUTURE, AND THE FUTURE OF OUR
SOULS.
YOU KNOW, THAT'S IT.
AND OUR MUSIC TO ME, HAS
REALLY HIT OUR HEARTS BECAUSE
IT'S NOT SOPHISTICATED.
IT REALLY HITS OUR HEARTS THE
WAY, IT'S JUST SO BEAUTIFUL.
IT REALLY BRINGS A SENSE OF
COMMUNITY TOGETHER AND IT'S SO
BEAUTIFUL.
AND ALSO OUR SENSE OF
ORGANIZATION
.
THESE FOLKS ARE THE MOST
ORGANIZED PEOPLE AMONG THE
LATINO PEOPLE.
AND IT'S BECAUSE IN OUR OWN
HOMELAND WE'RE NOT UNITED BUT
WE COME HERE AND WE'RE BEING
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST.
YOU KNOW, IN OUR PLACE, IN MAD
MADERA COUNTY, JUST NORTH OF
FRESNO COUNTY.
OUTSIDE OF MEXICO.
AND THERE, YOU KNOW, ALWAYS OF
MEXECOS, WHERE DO WE GET OUR
GREEN, RIGHT?
THE GOOD STUFF?
IT'S FROM
THE MARKET.
SUNDAY.
WHEN WE DON'T WORK.
SO WHAT DO THEY DO?
THEY CHARGE $1 EVERY HEAD.
I DON'T SEE PEOPLE, GOING TO
THE GIANT OR WHATEVER.
ANY KIND OF GROCERY STORES.
AND HAVING TO PAY TO GET IN.
BUT THAT'S THE KIND OF EXPLOIT
EXPLOITATION WE CAN TAKE.
SO I SEE, THERE ARE A LOT WE
NEED TO PRESERVE AS INDIOS AND
ALSO OUR IDENTITY.
I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS MY FATHER INSTILLED ON
US AS A FAMILY.
WE SHOULD BE PROUD TO BE INDIO
INDIOS, TO HAVE A RICH HISTORY
HISTORY, A RICH TRADITION AND
IT'S A LOT FOR US TO CONFIGURE
TO THIS COMMUNITY TO MAKE
AMERICA, EVEN BETTER THAN WHAT
IT IS.
SO ANYWAY, THAT'S WHAT I SEE.
>> I BELIEVE THAT TRADITION IS
A SOCIAL CONSTRUCTION.
SO WHEN THE PEOPLE WANT TO
CHANGE SOMETHING THAT IS NOT
BENEFICIAL TO SAY LIKE WOMEN],
WOMEN],THEN WE HAVE THE POWER
TO DO THAT.
THE COMMUNIDAD.
THEY HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
CHANGE IT
THERE'S A BALANCE IN
TRADITIONS, WHERE, FOR EXAMPLE
EXAMPLE, MY DAD BELIEVED VERY
STRONGLY IN DOING CERTAIN
THINGS AND THE CIRCUMSTANCES,
YOU KNOW, HE LEFT WHEN I WAS
11.
I GREW UP IN BOYLE HEIGHTS,
EAST L.A.
WHEN HE LEFT, BEFORE HE LEFT,
HE DIDN'T ALLOW ENGLISH IN THE
HOUSE WHATSOEVER.
THAT WAS THE TRADITION OF THE
HOME.
NO ENGLISH.
NOTHING HE COULDN'T UNDERSTAND
UNDERSTAND.
WHEN HE LEFT, YOU KNOW, MUSIC
AND ENGLISH
ROCK 'N' ROLL, R&B
STARTED COMING UP INTO THE
HOUSE.
SO THE CIRCUMSTANCES WERE, THE
MAN WAS OUT OF THE HOUSE, SO
MY MOM WAS LIKE, YEAH, SURE,
GO AHEAD.
LISTEN TO WHATEVER YOU WANT.
SO WE WERE LIKE, YEAH!
WHEN I THINK OF CULTURES, DEEP
DEEP, TRADITIONAL CULTURES
AND OTHERS.
I THINK IT'S ALWAYS GOOD TO
HAVE, WHEN I THINK ABOUT MY
DAD, I THINK IT'S AUTOS GREAT
THAT HE DIDN'T ALLOW ENGLISH
IN THE HOUSE BECAUSE I WAS
ABLE TO LEARN THE LANGUAGE TO
A CERTAIN EXTENT IN A WAY THAT
WAS REALLY IMPORTANT TO ME
LATER N TERMS OF EXPRESSION
AND ALL OF THESE THINGS, BUT
IN TERMS OF ALLOWING NEW
SOUNDS, REALLY OPENED MY EYES
TO OTHER THINGS AS WELL.
BUT TO HAVE THE BALANCE OF
PEOPLE IN EVERY TRADITION.
THE DIE-HARDS THAT JUST WANT
TO KEEP IT, THEY BELIEVE THAT
TRADITION IS NONSTATIC, THAT
YOU JUST NEED TO KEEP CERTAIN
TRADITIONS.
AND HAVE OTHER PEOPLE, THEY
SAY LIKE, YOU KNOW WHAT,
TRADITION NEEDS  TO CHANGE.
TRADITION IS FLUID FOR THIS
AND IT IS EVER CHARGING.
I THINK I BELIEVE BOTH OF
THOSE.
WE NEED THOSE TWO.
LIVES.
YES, NO,.
[LAUGHTER]
YOU KNOW, WE NEED THAT BALANCE
BALANCE, AND SOME OF THE
THINGS WE REALLY NEED TO
CHANGE.
BUT I THINK EVERY PERSON PLAY
ACE ROLE.
>> IT'S AN INTERESTING THING
ABOUT TRADITION, ISN'T IT?
EVERYONE IS A VIBRANT HUMAN
BEING AND EVERY GROUP HAS A
VIBRANT LIFE AND EVERY CULTURE
IS A VIBRANT, LIVING,
BEAUTIFUL, HAS A BEAUTIFUL
SYSTEM OF DOING ALL THESE
THINGS.
WHAT HAPPENS IS, WE PUT POWER
INTO THE PICTURE.
WE PUT A DROP OF POWER OR A
GALLON OF POWER, THEN ONE
GROUP BECOMES TRADITIONAL AND
OTHER GROUP BECOMES MODERN.
LIFE TAKEN, AND USED
COMMERCIALLY AND THAT GROUP,
SOMEHOW THROUGH VARIOUS
PROCESSES, IS KIND OF KEPT AT
THE MARGIN.
SO THAT'S WHEN WE RUN INTO
PROBLEMS, YOU KNOW, BUT WE
HAVE INDIAN WOMEN'S WEAVING
AND
PLACES FOR WOMEN OR
APPAREL W WEAVING AND PATTERNS
PATTERNS.
COMMERCIALLY YOU REALLY STEP
INTO THE CULTURE AND YOU
REALLY LOOK.
IT'S KIND OF JUST BEEN
MARKETED.
REALLY, WITHOUT ANY DEEP
NOTIONS OF IT
THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF CORPORATE DISPLAYS
AND CLASS 1 AND THE GROUP OF
WHERE THE MATERIAL COMES FROM,
IS KEPT AT BAY.
IT'S KEPT ON THE SIDE AND ON
THE OUTSIDE.
WHEN IN FACT F YOU LOOK AT
THOSE PATTERNS, AND MIN
TERRITORY, PERHAPS WEAVING
TRADITION, ARE THOSE SYMBOLS,
COLORS, AND PATTERNS, HAVE
MANY DEEP STORIES CONNECTED TO
THEM.
AND THEY'RE KIND OF STORIES OF
THE CREATION, AND STORY OF A
VILLAGE, AND THE WEAVER, SO
THAT'S WHAT GETS CRITICAL WHEN
I LOOK INTO IT, WHEN I THINK
ABOUT IT.
ONE GROUP HAS APOLOGIZE, AND
THE OTHER GROUP DOESN'T.
AND THEN THE OTHER GROUP USES
THOSE QUOTE, UNQUOTE,
TRADITIONS  TO KIND OF DISPLAY
ITSELF AS A CULTURAL,
DEMOCRATIC OR PLURAL GROUP AND
YET THE RESOURCES ARE REALLY
GOING TO THE QUOTE, UNQUOTE,
TRADITIONS ARE ROOTED IN.
SO THAT'S WHAT GETS ME.
BECAUSE EVERYONE HAS TRADITION
TRADITION.
AND YET, SOMEHOW, VARIOUS
GROUPS AT TIMES, WE DON'T HAVE
ANYMORE TRADITIONS.
WE'RE KIND OF MODERN NOW, AND
WE'RE JUST KIND OF BEING
OURSELVES, AND BEING A HUMAN
BEING.
WEARING MATERIALS AND ITEMS
AND PIXELS, AND THE OTHER
GROUP IS CHEWING CORN AND
BURNING YERBA AND WE HAVE TO
RESPECT THE RERBA AND THE
BURNING.
FOR ME, IT'S THE MOST
IMPORTANT TO CREATE UNITY AND
TO HAVE KIND OF A DEEPER
TO OPEN THE FLOW OF THE
RESOURCES, AND LET DEEP
KNOWLEDGE FLOW FROM ALL
PEOPLES, IN PARTICULAR, THOSE
THAT WE THINK HAVE TRADITIONS,
WHICH THEY DO, BUT NOT IN A
CORPORATE
MANNER,
BRUIN A
VIBRANT, EVOLVING MANNER.
TO THIS DAY, WE HAVE KEPT EACH
OTHER APART AND WE HAVE PUSHED
PUSHED, IN ONE WAY OR ANOTHER.
OUR BEAUTIFUL INDIGENOUS
GROUPS, TO THE OUTSIDE AND
FEEL THAT WE ARE ON THE INSIDE
INSIDE.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, WE ARE ON
THE OUTSIDE.
I THINK IT'S ONE THING THAT
JUAN FELIPE HERRERA AND
EVERYBODY AND THAT LATINO
CULTURE IN GENERAL IS SEEKING
TO EXPLORE AND UNDERSTAND.
AS PART OF THIS, OUR PROGRAM
IS RUNNING DOWN, BUT DOWN, BUT
PIED LIKE
JUAN TO READ A POEM, WHICH WAS
ACTUALLY WRITTEN BY STUDENTS
AT FIRST AND THEN WRITTEN AS
PART OF JUAN FILIPE'S WORLD'S
LONGEST POEM PROJECT, WHICH IS
ONE OF THE POST LAUREATE
PROJECTS, THAT'S BEEN GOING ON
AND SO IF JUAN FELIPE HERRERA,
IN ORDER TO CLOSE THIS OUT
THIS EVEN AND IN ORDER TO
SHARE BOTH YOUR WORDS, AND THE
WORDS OF OTHERS, BRINGING
DIFFERENT VOICES AND MULTIPLE
CHOICES TOGETHER.
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE SHARE THAT
WITH US.
>> THIS IS SO BEAUTIFUL, YOU
KNOW, EVERYONE THAT'S HERE
RIGHT NOW, JUST BY HANGING OUT
AND SAYING HELLO AGAIN.
WHAT ABOUT YOU, WELL, I JUST
GOT THIS GUITAR RECENTLY.
REMEMBER THE RADIO?
YEAH, WHY DON'T WE GET BACK
INTO IT, YOU KNOW.
LET'S WRITE A SONG TOGETHER.
SO YOU SEE, THAT'S HOW TO DO
IT, DON'T YOU THINK?
YEAH.
THAT'S HOW WE CAN DO IT.
IT'S ART AND CREATIVITY ARE
OPEN DOORS.
THEY'RE A COLLECTIVE
PRISM OF
OPEN DOORS.
WE GET INSPIREED AND WE WANT TO
CLAP.
THAT'S THE IDEA AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS IS ALL ABOUT.
SO WHAT HAPPENED IS, I WENT TO
WYOMING, TO JACKSONVILLE,
WYOMING AND IT WAS A BEAUTIFUL
NIGHT WITH COMMUNITIES THERE,
AND THERE ARE A LOT OF
BEAUTIFUL WORK WITH THE
MIGRANT STUDENTS AND IN THE
HIGH SCHOOLS, AND THE JUNIOR
HIGH SCHOOLS.
SO I WITHIN INTO THE MIDDLE
SCHOOL, AND TO THE 8TH GRADE
CLASS.
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN, L HOW ARE
YOU?
AND THEN THE STUDENT SAID,
WELL, JUAN FILIPE, WE SAW THAT
YOU HAD A POEM.
OH.
VERY GOOD.
AND WE NOTICE THAT YOU WROTE A
POEM CALLED EVERY DAY WE GET
MORE ILLEGAL.
REALLY?
IS THAT THE POEM YOU'RE
TALKING WITH? ABOUT?
OKAY.
IT'S A REALLY GOOD POEM.
BUT YOU KNOW, WE KIND OF RE
REWROTE IT FOR YOU.
[LAUGHTER]
I THINK I'M GOING TO SIT DOWN
NOW, YOU GO RIGHT AHEAD.
THIS IS IT.
AND I'M TELLING YOU, IT IS.
A MUCH BETTER PIECE.
IT IS.
THE NAME OF THE POEM IS "EVERY
DAY WE GET MORE ILLEGAL."
LEFT FOR AMERICAA ON PLANE,
BUSES, ADVANCE, THEY SAID.
I REMEMBER.
UNDER THE SILVER DARKNESS, IT
IS ALL IN BETWEEN THE LIGHT.
I IMAGINE GOING THROUGH A
TUNNEL, TO A BETTER LIFE,
BUILT BY A FUTURE, YET, YOU
STAY BROKEN.
I HAVEN'T SEEN MY PARENTS IN 9
YEARS.
MY MOM SAID.
MY GRANDMA, MY UNCLE.
MY ENTIRE FAMILY LEFT TO
MEXICO.
RARE VISITS FOR THE LUCKY ONCE
ONCE.
EXPIRED VISA, BOARDS AT DIVIDE
MEANS THEY WON'T COME ANYMORE.
I DON'T KNOW HALF OF WHO I AM
MISSING.
MY DAD'S THANK YOU RANCH LA,
MY MOM'S TURTLE.
LEFT BEHIND.
DEPRESSION HOPES, DREAMS, OUR
CULTURE, LONG, TAKEN AWAY.
HOW CAN AMERICA BE THE LAND OF
THE FREE IF YOU CAN'T FEEL IT
WALKING, WORKING, WITH OUR
MIND, OUR LIFE.
MIDDLE SCHOOL, LATINO LEADER.
WOW.
[APPLAUSE]
.
>> PLEASE JOIN ME IN THANKING
JUAN FELIPE HERRERA BEING POST
LAUREATE.
[APPLAUSE]
.
ALL RIGHT.
DON'T GO AWAY.
OR I SHOULD SAY, TAKE A 10
MINUTE BREAK.
GO TO THE RESTROOM, GO AND
LOOK AT THE BEAUTIFUL EXHIBITS
THAT ARE RIGHT OUT IN THE FOY
FOYER FEATURING SOME OF THE
WONDERFUL COLLECTION FROM THE
LIBRARY.
GET SOMETHING TO DRINK.
COME BACK, STRETCH YOUR LEGS
AND GET READY TO DANCE.
TO QUETZAL.
[BREAK TAKEN]
SHALLSHALL WE START?
YEAH!
PRACTICAL MUSIC [
[MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE].
SO WE LIKE TO TELL STORIES AS
WELL, THROUGH POETRY AND MUSIC
MUSIC, FROM THE GREAT
TRADITION OF JUAN FELIPE
HERRERA.
WE HAVE BEEN, OUR DIRECT A
SENDANTS OF THE MOVEMENT LIKE
HE AND PEOPLE LIKE LOUIE PEREZ
HAVE SPAWNED.
SO THIS NEXT SONG IS ABOUT
STRUGGLE, AND THE STRUGGLE WE
SAW IN MEXICO, AFTER SEEING A
CHILD BE A FIRE BREATHER ON
THE STREETS FOR CHANGE.
IT WASN'T BECAUSE HE WAS PART
OF SOME PRESTIGIOUS CIRCUS,
BUT BECAUSE HE WAS TRYING TO
MAKE A LIVING FOR HE AND HIS
FAMILY AND IT WAS ONE OF THE
SADDEST THINGS I'VE EVER SEEN,
AND THIS SONG WAS WRITTEN AS A
RESULT OF THAT.
[MUSIC]
MARTHA GONZALEZ, EVERYBODY.
WE CALL HER LA PROFE.
WE'D LIKE TO INVITE ONE OF OUR
MENTORS AND LIKE MARTHA SAID,
THE PERSON WHO CAN CALL US HIS
SPAWN.
IS THAT WHAT YOU SAID?
>> THE MOVEMENT HE SPAWNED.
OH.
AUTOMOBILE ACCIDENT.
SORRY.
I MISINTERPRETED.
LOUIE PEREZ.
[APPLAUSE].
VENGA PACA CON MIS NOSOTROS
SO
WE TALKED TRADITION EARLIER.
AND I WANT LOUIE TO SAY A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT HE SAID
BACK STAGE B PANEL.
AND TRADITION.
ARIZONA HE'S SETTING UP.
SINCE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TRADITION, SORRY.
I'M STILL OUT OF BREATH.
OKAY.
THIS TUNE SAY TRADITIONAL TUNE
THAT WE HAVE ROCKED OUT.
IT'S CALLED LA LLORONCITA.
AND WE LEARNED ROCKING OUT
WITH LOUIE PEREZ AND LOS LOBOS
LOBOS.
GIVE IT UP FOR HIM, YA'LL.
[APPLAUSE]
Si pasas por el rosal
Cuidado con las espinas
No te vayas a espinar
Porque la sangre lastima
Sin poderlo remediar
Ay de mi Llorona
Pero dejame llorar
A ver si llorando puede
Mi Corazon descansar
Con la luz de un Nuevo dia
Se ha calmado mi llorar
Si es que no te conocia
Es que no te supe amar
Ahora empiezo a caminar
Con tu mano vida mia
Ay de mi Llorona
Pero dejame llorar
A ver si llorando puede
Mi Corazon descansar
El Toro Zacamandu de Ayotzinapa
.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
LLORANDO PUEDE.
[APPLAUSE].
WE ARE CALIFORNIA UP HERE,
YA'LL.
NOT TOO FAR AWAY FROM EAST
L.A.
MONTEREY PARK.
JAPANESE,
THAI BUT SPEAK
SPANISH.  CALIFORNIA.
LUIS, WE'RE GOING TO CALL HIM
BACK UP HERE IN JUST A BIT.
SO WE'RE STORY TELLERS AND WE
LIKE TO NARE ATE WHAT'S
HAPPENING OUT THERE.
AND ALSO MAKE CONNECTIONS
BETWEEN THE PAST AND THE
PRESENT.
SOME OF OUR PROBLEMS, BUT ALSO
ASKING PROBLEMS, SOME OF OUR
SOLUTIONS.
THAT WE SEE THAT ARE POSSIBLE.
AND THIS SONG IS CALLED "
CALLED "CRITICAL TIME" AND IT
ACTUALLY SPAWNED, THERE'S THAT
WORD AGAIN, THE TITLE OF OUR
NEW ALBUM CALLED "THE ETERNAL
GET-DOWN"."
HERE WE GO.
¶
People asking “Why?”
Mother’s crying, “Cry”
Authorities building lies
It's a critical time
Books and faces, faces in books
Where the truth weathers
Through moving pictures
Recording deaths that spark
A million man march
It is no coincidence
The collective skin tone of the
innocent
Sparks in all of us
A discontent
Initiating those
Who were once reticent
Moment in time
People asking “Why?”
Mother’s crying, “Cry”
Authorities building lies
It's a critical time
Moment in time
Times of the moment
Riots, Patrolmen
People and Showmen
Chanting soon dissipates
As infiltrates instigate
People disperse
As the suffering
The Media soon mitigates
Sparks in all of us a
discontent
Initiating those who were once
reticent
How do you harness the energy
of the march?
How do you instill the momentum
given the dark?
Beyond the picket, the boycott
and the trend that will soon be
abated
That all of these deaths are
interrelated
Ferguson, Emmett, Guerrero and
Brown
How do we initiate our people
to
The Eternal Get Down?
para sanar
Critical Time
People asking “Why?”
Mother’s crying, “Cry”
Authorities building lies
It's a critical time
OOH, ¶ OO
OOH.
OH, OH, OH,-OH,.
OOH, OOH, OHH.
OOH, OOH.
HEY, HEY, HEY, HEY
OOH, OOH, OHH.
OOH, OOH.
HEY, HEY, HEY, HEY
.
ASKING WHY.
OH!
ASK WHY, NO!
WHY, WHY, WHY, WHY?
WE NEED TO FEEL, WE NEED TO
FLY.
WE NEED TO
FILL INTO THE SKY.
OH, AYY!
OOH, OOH, OHH.
OOH, OOH.
[APPLAUSE].
EVERYBODY OKAY OUT THERE?
THIS IS SUCH A BEAUTIFUL
THEATER TO PLAY NICE, QUIET
MUSIC, RIGHT?
EVERYBODY'S HERE AND OKAY.
WE'RE ALL STILL DOING ALL
RIGHT?
OKAY.
I MUST SAY, YOU GUYS WERE
PRETTY CONSERVATIVE WHEN WE
WERE DOING THE PANEL.
BUT YOU'RE KIND OF ROQUEROS.
YOU'RE ROCKERS, RIGHT.
SO THE USHERS GAVE US
PERMISSION, THEY SAID IT'S
OKAY TO DANCE IN THE AISLES.
YOU JUST CAN'T ROLL DOWN.
IF YOU GET UP AND DANCE, I
PROMISE, NOBODY'S GOING TO
TAKE YOUR SEAT.
CLAP, CLAP, THERE YOU GO!
THERE YOU GO, LADIES.
COME ON DOWN HERE.
COME ON DOWN HERE IF YOU'D
LIKE.
SHOW THEM HOW IT'S DONE.
EVAN, EVAN!
EVERYBODY FREE.
FREE.
FREE FREE, FREE.
FREE, FREE, NO NO NO WALLS.
NO WALLS, NO WALLS.
NO WALLS.
NO BORDER WALL,.
NO BORDER, BORDER, BORDER WALL
WALL.
NO BORDER WALL, NO BORDER WALL
WALL, NO BORDER, BORDER,
BORDER, BORDER, BORDER WALL.
NO WALL.
FREE.
FREE, FREE.
LIBRE.
LIBRE TODO LIBRE.
NO WALL.
NO WA-WA-WA-W AWOL.
FREE.
WE FREE.
VERY FREE.
NO BORDER WALL.
NO LITTLE WALL.
NO BIG WALL.
NO BIG WALL, NO LITTLE WALL.
NO BIG WALL NO LITTLE WALL.
OKAY.
YOU DIDN'T KNOW THE POST
LAUREATE WAS AN M.C. YOU KNOW
WHAT I'M SAYING?
WOW.
WHAT'S UP WITH THAT?
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING
?
JUAN FELIPE HERRERA TREASURE
TROVE.
WE WANT TO CALL UP ANOTHER
TREASURE TROVE.
COME ON OUT HERE AGAIN, LOUIE
PEREZ.
GIVE IT UP FOR LOUIE, YA'LL.
WE CAN'T FIND HIM.
WHERE'S OLIVIA.WHEN YOU NEED
HIM.
LOUIE,!
LOUIE!
[CHANTING]
ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE GOING TO PLAY ANOTHER
ONE FOR YOU WHILE WE'RE
WAITING.
OKAY.
WHILE WE'RE WAITING FOR HIM.
ARIZONA SOON AS HE GETS HERE.
WAIT.
THERE HE IS!
YEAH!
ALL RIGHT.
THANKS A LOT.
I JUST WANT TO THANK BETSY
PETERSON AND EVERYBODY FOR GET
GETTING US ALL TOGETHER AND
BRINGING US OUT HERE.
IT'S VERY COOL.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
AND OF COURSE, WE'RE HERE TO
CELEBRATE JUAN FELIPE HERRERA
HERRERA'S TENURE HERE, AND
AGAIN, HERE'S A SONG ABOUT THE
LITTLE HOUSE IN UCLA, THE --
THE LITTLE HOUSE IN EAST L.A.
THAT I GREW UP IN.
IT'S CALLED STAIN BEHIND
THE
GLASS.
BABY IN HIS ARMS
.
STAIN BEHIND THE GLASS, HOLDS
A BABY IF HIS ARMS
.
WATCHING HIM ME SLEEP.
WATCHING ME SLEEP.
STAIN BEHIND THE GLASS, WATCH
WATCHING ME WHILE I SLEEP.
COFFEE IN THE AIR.
STAINED BEHIND THE AIR.
CURTAINS BLOWING AROUND.
CURTAINS BLOWING AROUND
.
CURTAINS BLOWING 'ROUND
NIGHT
UPON MY HEAD.
NIGHT UPON MY HEAD.
THINK BEHIND THE GLASS.
NIGHT UPON MY HEAD
.
NORTH DON'T CRY.
MOTHER DON'T CRY.
THINK BEHIND THE GLASS.
TELLS MOTHER NOT TO CRY
.
I CAN'T TELL WHAT YOU AN HONOR
IT IS TO BE HERE WITH YOU
TONIGHT.
I'M SO HONORED AND I'VE HAD
THE BEST TIME EVER.
SO THANK YOU, SO VERY MUCH.
AND IT WAS A REAL PLEASURE.
ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE GOING TO DO A SONG
CALLED PARA SANAR WHICH MEANS,
TO HEAL.
SO THIS SONG IS A GREAT
TRADITION AND TALK REALLY
ABOUT THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT
I SAW AS A CHILD, MEXICANO'S
DO THE HEAL AND YES, WE WENT
TO THE MEDICAL DOCTOR.
THE WESTERN MEDICAL DOCTOR.
BUT WE ALSO WENT TO CURANDEROS
AND YOU HAD
THE GRANDMA RUB
THE EGG OUR AND YOU LIT THE
GREEN CANDLED WHEN YOU WANTED
THE JOB AND HAD ALLOTOPIA DEAR
AND YOU FED SOMEBODY YOUR HAIR
WHEN YOU WANTED THEM TO FALL
IN LOVE WITH YOU.
THAT'S HOW I GOT THIS GUY
RIGHT HERE.
WHO KNOWS WHAT ELSE HE ATE.
JUST KIDDING.
SO.
POSSESSION FROM THE CURANDERA
AND THE BOTANICA.
THIS SONG IS ABOUT HEALING
THROUGH ANY MEANS NECESSARY,
THROUGH WORDS N LIFE.
NUEVAMENTE.
Hay que mandarle el padre que
lo venga a curar
Bendito santo un rompimiento
para sanar
Ve dile a mama que no llore, no
llore mas lagrima
Ve dile a mama que no llore,
orisha lo va cuidar
Ese espiritu malo que anda
sirve pa na
Ese espiritu inquieto que anda
es de papa!
Hay que mandarle el padre que
lo venga a curar
Bendito santo un rompimiento
para sanar
.
Bendito santo un rompimiento
para sanar
[APPLAUSE].
YEAH!
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LOUIE PEREZ!
QETZEL FLORES.
JUAN PEREZ ON BASS.
WE ARE EL MERO MEROEVAN GRIER
ON DRUMS.
JUAN FELIPE HERRERA ON
BEAUTIFUL VOCALS AND LONG,
LONG LEGACY, HERMANO, MAESTRO.
>> DR. MARTHA GONZALEZ
, YOU
GUYS.
>> OH.
THANK YOU.
I THOUGHT WE WERE DONE.
WHAT'S HAPPENING?
[APPLAUSE]
.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, AND THANK
YOU FOR THE AMAZING SOUND CREW
CREW.
EVERYBODY HERE, THANK YOU MUCH
MUCH.
LET'S GIVE IT UP.
LET'S GIVE ANOTHER HAND.
LET'S GIVE ANOTHER HAND FOR QU
QUETZAL AND LOUIE PEREZ!
WE.
JUAN FILIPE, COME ON UP!
COME ON UP!
COME ON!
THERE WE GO.
THE BAND IS COMPLETE.
YOU SHOULD HAVE SOME SURVEYS.
TELL US WHAT YOU THOUGHT
TONIGHT.
I HOPE YOU LIKED IT.
JUAN FELIPE HERRERA WILL SIGN
SOME BOOKS.